nous commençons donc par parler de cette
décision du président du medef geoffroy
roux de bézieux
c'est par un tweet publié ce matin qu'il
a annoncé que la table ronde sur les
populismes qu'il avait prévu d'organiser
lors des universités du medef à la fin
de l'été était annulé pourquoi et bien
parce que parmi les intervenants de
cette table ronde
il y avait marion maréchal et ça avait
suscité les protestations d'un certain
nombre de responsables politiques mais
aussi patronaux voici par exemple ce
tweet de laurence parisot
une ancienne présidente du medef qui
déclaré hier avant la décision de roux
de bézieux si cette information est
exacte
c'est très grave et puis je propose
d'écouter la réaction de françois de
rugy le ministre de l'écologie il était
ce matin sur france info
et lui est tout à fait ravi qu'on ait
des programmes et marion maréchal on
voit pas bien ce qu'elle venait faire là
sinon pour créer une sorte la russie de
buzz politico médiatique et valoriser
une personne qui par ailleurs n'a même
plus de mandat aujourd'hui et qui défend
des idées extrémistes si ces universités
d'été du medef sont des moments pour
réfléchir entre dirigeants économiques
et politiques sur la meilleure politique
économique de la france je pense que
c'est en effet la meilleure décision qui
a été prise
et puis avant de lancer le débat je vous
propose de prendre connaissance cette
réaction de louis aliot qui est député
rassemblement national des pyrénées
orientales
le medef supprime le débat prévu avec
marion maréchal à son université d'été
la france pays des lumières et de la
liberté mort de rire
l'extrême élite montre son vrai visage
celui de l'exclusion de la
discrimination du sectarisme
bernard de la villardière c'était une
bonne idée selon vous de d'annuler la
venue de marion maréchal jeu encore le
syndicat
dirigé par présidée par jean bézieux il
m'appartient pas de savoir s'il a bien
fait de l'invité et d'annuler cette
annulation après après tout c'est sa
liberté ça lui appartient
donc je serais intéressé de savoir
pourquoi il l'a fait ce que c'est à
cause du mauvais buzz qu'avait déclenché
cette invitation mais par nature moi je
trouve que il faut parler du populisme
et il faut débattre et et je pense que
marion maréchal-le pen marion mashaal ne
pas nous doit pas être ostracisés et
notamment dans par des organisations
comme comme le medef
enfin voilà la meilleure manière de
lutter contre les idées extrêmes
supposer qu'elles aient des idées
extrêmes parce que je pense que par
rapport à ce qui était le le parti
d'extrême droite à l'époque de son grand
père malgré tout ce parti ça un peu
recentrer dans contes ont dit qu'is
d'extrême droite
je crois que c'est plus compliqué que ça
c'est un parti populiste en effet ce en
apparence oui peut-être
oui voila je sais pas moi je suis pas
journaliste politique donc
mais j'ai l'impression en tout cas que
c'est plus ce que c'était
voilà c'était autrefois un refuge de
pétainiste de nostalgie certaine période
et c'est aujourd'hui notamment sur le
plan économique il ya entre marion
maréchal-le pen et sa tante des
différences l'une est plus libérale
l'autre est plus socialisante
anticapitaliste
l'extrême droite est aussi un volontiers
anti capitaliste donc voilà donc je
pense que enfin voila je trouve que ça
me et buzz
je déteste les excommunications par
principe donc voilà lé il se trouve
qu'en plus elle n'est pas député donc
elle n'est pas la seule à être des
commandes est aussi raquel garrido qui
était la porte parole de la france
insoumise c'est ça vous paraît bien
cette cette remise au pas de la de cette
manifestation du medef ce qui me paraît
intéressant c'est pas tant le fait que
le medef ait fait marche arrière et des
commandes et marion maréchal ex le pen
ce qui me paraît intéressant c'est
d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi le
medef l'avait invité moi c'est ça qui me
paraît intéressant parce que dans cette
affaire il ya aucune innocence
tout est calculé vous pensez bien que le
président du medef qui est un homme qui
sait où il va qui sait ce qu'il fait et
donc quand il invite marion maréchal à
son université d'été
il fait un acte politique qui a du sens
et sact acte politique c'est un message
qu'il adresse à une partie de la droite
pour lui dire allez-y
je vous accorde mon parrainage c'est à
dire le medef ne voit pas d'inconvénient
à ce qu'il y ait un rapprochement entre
l'extrême droit une façon d'un légitime
et bien sûr c'est une façon de dire ce
que marion maréchal essaye de faire
aujourd'hui en multipliant les
passerelles avec les républicains le
dîner qu'elle a auxquelles elle a
participé récemment les contacts qu'elle
a pris le medef dit au fond allez-y vous
pouvez y aller ça ne me gêne pas
tiendrai le même discours avec la france
insoumise non mais non rien comment
mettre sur le même plan
quelqu'un qui a qui a qui a des idées
qui sont totalement anti républicaine
avec avec la france insoumise mélenchon
c'est un républicain à ma connaissance
donc ça ne m les renvoyer dos à dos ça
c'est quelque chose que que je refuse le
vendra rien absolument mais bien sûr et
donc c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
quel était le sens politique de
l'invitation du medef est à marion
maréchal et là franchement cette façon
de dire ah mais allez-y parce que marion
maréchal c'est pas comme sa tante c'est
pas comme son grand père elle est plus
fréquentable et les moins extrémistes
allaient plus mais c'est de la
supercherie
parce qu'elle est aussi radicale que
que marine le pen que jean marie le pen
sur tous les plans que ce soit sur le
plan économique sur le plan des
questions de société
j'ai quelques citations de marion
maréchal qu'yves qui valent leur pesant
d'or sur un certain nombre de sujets
donc franchement là la faire apparaître
il ya tromperie sur la marchandise comme
l'était c'était de l'invité des départs
ou alors c'était une volonté délibérée
anne-charlotte bezina à mon sens il ya
plusieurs questions il ya d'abord la
question du sujet c'est à dire
qu'apparemment elle n'était pas invitée
par le medef pour soutenir un quelconque
propos économique où qu'ils soient en
lien avec l'activité du minefe c'est une
université d'été qui était une
université qui était censé parler d'un
sujet de société comme celui sur la peur
des populismes notamment et donc avoir
une université d'été sur le populisme
sans représentant de ce type de
mouvement pouvait apparaître quand même
relativement illégitime ou en tout cas
relativement peu profonds en terme à mon
avis de poids doctrinale et sert alors
bon elle a cette couverture un peu un
peu ambivalent d'ailleurs d'être à la
fois nos élus et donc de représenter une
forme de courant qui se veut presque
universitaire dans sa manière de mener
donc je pense qu'elle était en tout cas
on peut imaginer qu'au titre des
invitations apparemment il ya 250 qui
ont été lancés un candidat potentiel
pour un type de conférences comme celui
ci le choix du moment
par contre est peut-être un petit peu
plus délicat puisque c'est vrai qu'elle
est en plein rapprochement dans une
véritable campagne politique finalement
pour revenir sur la scène et donc la
faire passer pour une intellectuelle de
ce moment là alors qu elle retente
finalement une entrée en politique et
peut-être un petit peu ce qui cause
notre débat d'aujourd'hui à mon avis
ensuite reste la dernière question qui
pour moi est la plus fondamentale c'est
comment traiter ce populisme ou en tout
cas ce qu'on appelle l' extrémisme
aujourd'hui et je vous rejoins là dessus
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse vraiment
considérer que ce parti est encore
l'extrémisme au sens où on l'a entendu
par exemple sous la troisième ou la
quatrième république on n'est plus dans
des parties qui se veulent populaire ou
en tout cas revendiquer ou les
aspirations du peuple ce qui peut être
encore plus dangereux mais est ce qu'il
vaut mieux les marginaliser
au contraire discuter avec pour les
mettre en défaut j'ai toujours tendance
à préférer la deuxième solution en tout
cas les français qui suivent le
figaro.fr sont d'accord avec vous
puisque c'est la question du jour sur
notre site internet
le medef at il eu raison d'annuler
l'invitation de marion maréchal et vous
répondez non 1 72%
paul françois paoli et si finalement le
medef rendait service à marion maréchal
en là on l'a déprogrammant c'est à dire
en accréditant l'idée qu' il ya une
partie de de l'opinion politique en
france qui n'est pas représenté et qui
n'est pas écoutée par ce qu'on appelle
les élites
oui je pense que moi je suis je ne
confonds pas le l'argument monsieur
smadja et au nom des valeurs
républicaines il développe un argument
qui est liberticide
si rien d'autre que vous faites je vois
pas au nom de quoi répond au nom de quoi
une association un mouvement comme le
medef mais comme n'importe quel
mouvement n'a pas le droit mais s'ils
ont tout allait donc le medef a fait bon
soit il devait l'invité il devait
jusqu'au bout mais il fallait surtout
pas reculé mais dans quel pays et on en
qualité et en quelle ce monsieur de rugy
ou madame toujours fléchiront rémy la
légitimité à quelle est la légitimité
d'un madame parisot pour dire qu'un
mélange lait maternel la wii grave en
quoi c'est grave en quoi de faire venir
en quoi madame marion maréchal et les
plus extrémistes que madame garrido je
vois pas en quoi chacun son radicalisme
que les choses soient claires je vais
vous dire une chose je n'ai même la mémé
gracile et bien elle même c'est la peau
télévision prix des réparations la
possibilité d'indiquer si non nous ne
sommes plus une démocratie libérale
nous sommes une démocratie libérale jeu
que vous que vous accusez vous accusez
orban de ces gens d'être délicat vous
avez développé un argument digne d'une
démocratie libérale elle n'est pas
républicaine dont elle ne doit pas
pourquoi pas sur les plateaux télévision
c'est pas que je n'ai même pas été
surpris de l'invitation faite par le
medef à marion maréchal et le medef fait
ce qu'il veut ça ne me regarde pas donc
je ne m'a pas à venir c'est bien assez
mal à convaincre les français sont un
différend sur qui m'intéressent après
deux contres
statistiques à l'if3 de cette invitation
parce que dans cette affaire il n'ya
jamais d'actes c'est une manière de
banaliser les idées du fraudeur duras en
national c'est une manière de cultiver
ce qui est facile parce qu'on connaît à
dano à mes yeux sans vie de culture et
puis alice est à l'opposé de ce qu'ils
croient et de et de séquestration
d'aller dans le sens de construire des
passerelles entre une partie de la
droite et l'extrême droite sur lequel on
peut être d'accord c'est qu'à priori
déprogrammation est toujours dangereuse
à partir du moment où c'est un acte qui
manquent de courage et je pense que
c'est comme vous l'avez dit mauvais buzz
c'est à dire qu'il ya quelque chose qui
a une forme de machine qui s'est enrayée
et qui a fait peur c'est légitime à un
dirigeant néanmoins je crois qu'on est
dans une société où ce buzz ne doit pas
gouverner et c'est malheureusement ce
qu'on voit trop souvent une évidence je
vous donne les points de vue de nos
internautes céderait qui le dit la
déprogrammation de marion maréchal est
grave
le medef ne veut pas entendre les
français et une femme dont les idées
sont libérales en tout cas plus libérale
sans doute que celle de sa tante
babineau les tentatives de
dédiabolisation des le pen me fascine
une majorité de français considère le
rassemblement national comme à part et
puis nicole 06 le manque de courage de
tout ce dirigeant et de tous ces
politiques est lamentable depuis quand
marion maréchal ou autres ne seraient
pas républicaine
moi ce que je pense elle c'est la
philosophique mans républicaine et en
courant est ce que c'est criminel
l epa phillies communiquer par e-mail
elle est l'héritière présente aux
élections rôle en matière de l'héritière
d'un courant historique et philosophique
qui s'appelle à droite légitimiste aller
à la limite la seule des zemmour a très
bien montré qu'ils avaient la droite
bono pas bonapartiste le gaulliste néo
gaulliste et ses allées sont même sa
tante et républicaine de sa tante marine
le pen est républicain dali jacobine on
peut pas accuser le rassemblement
national d'être trop jacobins et de ne
pas être républicain donc tous en tous
dépend de cette ce caractère polysémique
de ce mot républicain donc
philosophiquement elle est catholique
identitaire si vous voulez donc elle est
en rupture avec la norme république est
une démocratie qu'est ce que c'est
c est la possibilité pour tous les
courants idéologiques de s'exprimer moi
c'est ma délégation
moi je trouvais intéressant c'est de se
poser la question pourquoi est ce que le
medef n'a pas invité par exemple marine
le pen parce qu'après tout puisque on
invite on invite des parlementaires des
élus de la nation
après tout marine le pen elle a beaucoup
plus de légitimité elle et lé député est
là elle occupe un siège à l'assemblée
nationale voilà on comprend donc
pourquoi et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
invitent marion maréchal ça a du sens le
sens que ça c'est qu'on considère
qu'elle est plus fréquentable que marine
le pen c'est ça que le c'est ça le sens
que ça et excusez moi mais elle n'est
absolument pas plus fréquentable que
marine le pen parce que franchement sur
un certain nombre de sujets vous prenez
les positions de marion maréchal mais ça
va très très loin par exemple par
exemple la théorie du grand remplacement
à lomé c'est une oubliée au riz du grand
nom mais d'accord enfin toutes les
opinions ne se valent pas excusez moi
sensible quand même lardé en attendant
si je serai là sur ce plateau c'est aux
états unis fait pour dire un certain mot
est combiné à une liberté je suis
honnête je suis peut être pas partie de
ceux qui considèrent ces vauclusiens qui
les noms des deux se valent et klein
fond il n'y a rien à dire que tout se
vaut et bien sûr
quand je ne suis pas d'accord 1 comment
c'est pour ça qu ici on equi c'est pour
ça que je suis là c'est parce que
monsieur l'agglomération marion marion
maréchal m considère que le grand
emplacement c'est le danger numéro un
c'est-à-dire son biya oui bien sûr ma
foi on a le droit de on a le droit de
commenter quand même sinon on ne serait
pas là vont jouer de faire cette
émission si on ne peut pas commenter et
ses déboires et en toute liberté et en
toute liberté
on s'en réjouit marc angenot reichel csn
qui a dit par exemple que le mariage
homosexuel menait tout droit à la
polygamie
perso qu'un haut responsable politique
n'a osé dire ça elle l'a fait et ça
c'est pas c'est pas de l'extrémisme ça
sinon c'est donc franchement oui c'est
une opinion mais enfin en rien elle
n'est plus fréquentable que les autres
dirigeants mais j'évite de ressemblance
c'est que les invitations ont été
lancées avant l'histoire du dîner avec
les élus républicains et que donc oui
mais et que donc le medef s'est dit
c'est intéressant de d'avoir cette femme
et de la mettre face à raquel garrido
ça montre que le medef est ouvert aux
gens qui ne pensent pas comme eux et
puis il ya eu cette espèce de mouvement
de panique à la suite donc ceux de ce
dîner entre maria riesch elle est
responsable républicain et du coup la
sphère a pris une importance france qui
n'avait pas anticipé mais bon c'est ça
n'est qu'un point de vue je n'ai pas
d'information 2006 elle a tort quand
même de ce débat public est complètement
gelé et avec d il ya des comportements
qui sont pavlovien des cons dès qu'on
parle de certaines personnes de
certaines idées etc
je trouve ça détestable parce que
finalement c'est cette technique qui est
employée depuis 30 ans pour essayer de
disqualifier extrême-droite et ça ne
fait ça n'a fait que faire monter
l'extrême droite c'est ça qui est
terrible et je pense que celui c'est
jean viard qui est déjà de 30 ans a mis
en garde la gauche française en disant
attention vous êtes en train de perdre
l'électorat populaire ouvriers employés
etc
ces électeurs aujourd'hui les ouvriers à
majorité ils votent le pen etc c'est
intéressant de savoir pourquoi et moi
c'est une des mes frustrations c'est que
dans ces débats on essaye pas on fait
pas de sociologie en france de
sociologie et orale et c'est parce que
des partis comme le vôtre où il
et maintenant de votre sensibilité à mon
sens n'ont pas fait leur travail quand
on en est là aujourd'hui
voyez ce que je veux dire et je crois
que disqualifié diaboliser c'est pas la
bonne technique malheureusement je crois
pas que ce soit la bonne technique